this next clip is sort of funny but it's
also it's it's also kind of sad i don't
know why i
kind of got bummed out watching it dr
anthony fauci was on cnn yesterday with
wolf blitzer and wolf blitzer tried to
make
a baseball analogy to the pandemic and
the analogy was
dr fauci you like baseball i like
baseball
if this pandemic were a baseball game
what inning would we be in and dr fauci
just seeming
exhausted saying you know wolf
this isn't like baseball but i i
actually think there
is a baseball analogy that could be made
that dr fauci could use in the future
i'll tell you in a second but let's take
a look at the clip where are we dr fauci
as a country right now
in our fight against this virus uh
we're both baseball fans for example
what inning are we in
you know it you know it's it's not like
baseball
uh wolf because the inning that we're in
is going to depend on how we respond
and that's the issue because i mean if i
say we're in the seventh inning it's
almost over
and we have surges like we're seeing
throughout europe and the rest of the
world and the threat
of a surge that we're seeing now you
know
it's not measured in innings anymore
it's measured on what we do
to contain this okay so dr fauci is
correct
in the sense that we're only in the
seventh inning
if people behave one way and otherwise
it might really only be like the fourth
inning or the fifth
inning and we have a long way to go here
is me
workshopping a better baseball analogy
tell me what you think about this
you know wolf the pandemic isn't a game
it's really like a world series
where you have to win four games to
actually win so the question is
are we going to sweep this in four or is
it going to go
seven because we don't finish off the
virus as quickly as we could
right that's the baseball analogy what i
can tell you wolf is
we have one more game to win but will it
be a sweep
or will this go seven games right uh you
could maybe you could even go further
game one
testing and controlling the spread uh
game
two uh scaling up testing and
researching vaccines game three
developing and testing the vaccines game
four
finishing vaccination to end the
pandemic and then next year
you might have another world series
right variants potentially new vaccines
the other baseball analogy i was
thinking of that might work would be
listen wolf we're in the seventh inning
but the virus is trying to catch up and
if they do
and and we have a tie then we go extra
innings
and as you know wolf extra innings can
go on indefinitely until someone wins
and we don't want that
every time a red state doesn't have
enough people wanting the vaccine
the virus has just knocked in a single
if the virus gets enough of these
singles it's going to start putting runs
up on the board am i going too far with
this
regardless we all share dr fauci's
exhaustion with this
if it's game four and you can finish it
off
or have to play another game you power
through
the exhaustion and that's what we're
hopefully doing with three and a half
million vaccinations a day
we're going to have to deal with the
pause on the johnson and johnson vaccine
over the blood clot fears as i told you
earlier
uh but big picture i mean like do you
think
it's a problem that wolf blitzer and
others use
these whether it's sports analogies or
whatever the case may be
like on one hand there really is no
analogy to something with a defined
duration
because the duration is is whatever we
make it new zealand just stopped this
you could say they walked off the field
after the first inning and said we don't
have to play the rest of the game
because there's almost nothing left to
do they controlled it so well i don't
know i don't know if maybe the sports
analogies or the fight analogies
that are sometimes used maybe it makes
it more relatable
maybe it just makes it more confusing to
people let me know what you think